studying anything at all that has a kind
of distance from our moment is the thing
that will actually give you some
perspective
on what's happening right now any kind
of cultural context that has some
foreignness some strangeness will then
by comparison bring certain aspects of
our own moment in high relief
I'm Faisal Mohammed I'm a professor of
English specializing in early modern
English literature especially people
like Hobbs Milton and Marvel
the 17th century was the time when in so
many ways the modern world took shape
this is a period of Mass Social upheaval
it's a period of mass migration it's a
period of Civil War it's a period when
the King was executed and England began
a great political experiment and that's
the setting of The Writers I study
Milton was not just a great poet the
Titanic figure in English poetry but
also he was a great poet revolutionary
he was the first English thinker to
defend and print the execution of King
Charles the first
studying Milton
draws us out of
casual assumptions we might have about
what it is that poetry does
we tend now to think of poetry as
beautiful and useless to borrow a title
that's not at all how Milton thought of
poetry for Milton it was both beautiful
and transformative the way that Milton
knows intimately the entire European
literary tradition leading up to
everyone from Homer and Virgil up to
writers of his own moment the amount of
knowledge that he had was simply
staggering and he can draw on all of it
and use it as a weapon as it were to
write a work of literature that
defiantly says all of the other epic
poets conceived of the project of epic
poetry incorrectly this is the Epic
truly married to truth and to use that
truth as a weapon against the restored
English Monarchy the restored English
church that's a sort of energy within a
work like Paradise Lost that I find
endlessly fascinating
there's no other
great poet who had Milton's
revolutionary Investments there's no
other revolutionary who is so great a
poet
yes he was a radical no but we would not
want to join him in his particular
radical vision and this is where one's
relationship to Milton gets complicated
you can admire his revolutionary energy
even as you see that the particular
Revolution he was fighting for is not
one you would want to join what Milton
really wanted looks to us now like an
oligarchy of white male Protestants so
the content of his ideas would want to
disown and yet the activist energy you
can still admire especially in its
relationship to Poetic achievement you
can't divorce one from the other and I
think that we can hold those two things
in our head at the same time we can say
this is brilliant even as we say
this guy was kind of a jerk and yet I
still I still admire him as a great
writer and thinker I think these writers
become a lot more interesting when we're
willing to to look at the good and the
bad and to see them in their full
complexity
[Music]